latest travel news here's John the busy
streets of Westminster but there's one
person that hasn't been spotted here for
a while the Prime Minister accused of
going to ground since last Friday's
disastrous mini budget we finally heard
from her today but not where you might
expect Liz truss welcome to the wake up
call Lydia says Are you ashamed of what
you've done are you a round of
pre-scheduled interviews on Regional
radio Liz truss in Downing Street faced
questions from across the country and it
was a bumpy ride the pound has dropped
to a record low the IMF has said that
you should re-evaluate your policies a
couple of people have said to me here in
Nottingham this is like a reverse Robin
Hood later still in Downing Street the
Prime Minister finally spoke on camera
it was the right decision to take and we
need to continue to make sure we deliver
the economic growth that we deliver the
jobs and opportunities and that is the
long-term future that we have set out
the new prime minister just three weeks
into the job has already come close to
an economic crisis now she faces a
political one with her first
conservative conference as leader just
days away many of her colleagues have
said they're not going an early sign of
deep disunity and division that has left
her and her Chancellor quasiquartang
pleading with their party stick together
or risk losing power
in a letter to Tori MPS the chancellor
wrote colleagues I understand your
concern we are one team and need to
remain focused the only people who will
win if we divide is the labor party and
his concerns were quickly confirmed by
an extraordinary new poll putting labor
33 points ahead of the conservatives
their biggest lead since the 1990s on
course for a blair-like landslide
and there are more tricky moments ahead
for the chancellor because his tax cuts
will require him to make big savings
elsewhere today he also faced his
critics but wouldn't say where those
cuts will fall it's premature for me to
come to a decision on that but that we
are absolutely focused on making sure
that the most vulnerable in our society
are protected through what could be a
challenge
union bosses were unconvinced and
preparing for a fight what we really
need to see is the government's changing
its mind about those tax cuts the Prime
Minister should sit down with public
sector unions let's set out a course for
revitalizing local book services to get
the funding that we need to make sure
those Services can deliver for millions
of people up and down the country also
feeling confrontational the bank of
England who dismissed the government's
claims that recent economic turmoil was
caused by global factors with their
Chief Economist saying there is
undoubtedly a UK specific component
another blow for a government whose
pursuit of growth is starting to look
like it could cost them big Liz Bates
Sky News Westminster